our top story this hour a federal judge
in Texas ruled that President Obama's
Affordable Care Act is unconstitutional
last night's decision said the tax bill
passed last year knocked the
constitutional foundation from under
Obamacare by eliminating a penalty for
not having health coverage after the
decision President Trump tweeted that
Congress should pass a new law to
protect coverage for people with
pre-existing conditions Obamacare will
remain in place while appeals proceed
now for some perspective on this and
other developments we turn to Bob Cusack
editor-in-chief of the hill Bob good
morning warm Sun on its face it seems as
though this is a big win for the White
House but I'm curious you know in the
midterm elections the Affordable Care
Act was a big issue yep could this
possibly backfire in the Republicans it
could I mean legally as you mentioned
huge win for Republicans but not all
Republicans joined this lawsuit they
don't agree with this lawsuit so
politically this is a problem for
Republican leaders because now all of a
sudden Obamacare is actually popular
compared to years ago so this is a
problem for Republican leaders how they
handle this and now Democrats you saw
the press releases last night going on
the offensive saying they're gonna join
this lawsuit and try to help overturn it
we're head probably headed to the
Supreme Court on this as we saw already
the president's making a pitch or at
least a you know an open claim saying he
wants to fix this pre-existing condition
problem is there the possibility that
Republicans and Democrats can come
together on something like this I think
there's a chance that it's slimming on
though it's no champion they can't agree
on funding the government I don't think
they can agree on any type of
legislative solution for health care you
don't think the Democrats will want to
help them here well I think that they
they want to help but at the same time I
just think it's too divisive the 2020
presidential cycle has already started
yep moving to Mick Mulvaney this seemed
like the most important job that hardly
anybody wanted what do you know about
his temperament and how he might be able
to manage the president which was
difficult for his predecessors he has a
good working relationship with the
president like other Republicans before
the president was elected he did
criticize the president publicly however
he's working at the budget office now
remember he's not resigning
that office so right doesn't like this
job maybe he'll go back so I think it's
kind of a win-win for the White House
and Mulvaney Mulvaney is a conservative
he likes to keep government spending
under control trump is really doesn't
want to tackle those type of issues at
least not in the first term so there's
the rub this is one of the toughest jobs
normally and in the Trump administration
it's the toughest job possibly ever
let's move on to the Muller
investigation and now Michael Cohen has
come out swinging President Trump came
back and said you know I did do no wrong
and then Cohen DoubleDown yeah
it's interesting the timing of Muller
here remember before Thanksgiving Muller
got the answers the written answers from
Trump's team and then all of a sudden we
see this massive Michael cone news and
how he's talking to Muller so maybe that
was to get okay let's get you in writing
first and then get all the the dirt from
Michael Cohen
the president has had in this
investigation I think a rough couple of
weeks man afford lying to Muller was a
setback for Muller but now there will
have been a lot of people now who have
flipped on Trump and he's got to be
nervous about that all right we'll see
what happens thank you so much Bob thank
you